هذا سوف يقوض الخمسة التي لن يحصل عليها خلال 24
ساعات التبديل والتي تحتاج إلى إيقاف تشغيلها ستكون أقل
أكثر موهبة منه، بالطبع سيكون لديه بديل
بدائل لأي من هذا القبيل إذا نظرت إلى الصورة على الإطلاق
بما أعتقد أنهم إذا أجلوا حتى التصفية
وأعلى لحم الخنزير من جهة إطلاق سراح الرهائن من جهة أخرى
لذا بالطبع من حيث الأهمية فهو على نفس القدر من الأهمية
ومن حيث الأولوية فالإفراج عن المختطفين شيء
الأمر الأكثر إلحاحاً بالنسبة لدولة إسرائيل هو شخص ذو بعد الفانك
فانيلي ثقيل جدًا وأود أن أقول أكثر من ذلك
Doctrinaire هو مصمم مع السنوار
مسار حماس المتطرفة في السنوات الأخيرة
هذا هو الشخص الذي كان في الواقع في العقد الماضي
تم إطلاق سراح شوهار من السجن عام 2010 كجزء من صفقة ما
التركيز في الواقع يعزز شيئين رئيسيين
الاستراتيجيون في حماس أول شيء هو كل النشاط
أمام الأسطورة الغربية التي أذكرها في أيام
العالم السابق قبل السابع من أكتوبر تلك الأسطورة
كنا مهتمين بشكل أساسي بكونه إنسانًا
الشخص الرئيسي الذي دربناه هو الشخص الذي ظهر اسمه
كإقصاء محتمل درسناه من قبل خلال
وبعد السبعة في أكتوبر الذي نحتاجه جميعا
حان الوقت لانتقاد كلمات المرور العامة وجميع أنواع الأطروحات
والتي من المفترض أن تبدو رائعة في العروض التقديمية ولكني لا أفعل ذلك
أعرف كيف يترجمون في الميدان عندما أنظر إليهم
لدي الكثير من علامات الاستفهام حول الخطوة ج
أما التنفيذ العملي فأنا على سبيل المثال أرى حماس كذلك
مع الأطراف الباردة، حتى الأشخاص المتضررين للغاية يبقون على قيد الحياة
ويقول حتى لو في هيئتنا أبدو سخيفا
لقد تمكنت من تحمل هذا السويد، وهو ليس حدثًا جيدًا
لدى إسرائيل استبطان إسرائيلي مهم جداً هنا
شمس على مدى السنتين والنصف والثلاث سنوات الماضية
لم تعد الحركة المحلية حركة
Azit التي تعمل حصرا داخل قطاع غزة
في الواقع، لقد غيرت حماس جغرافية قطاع غزة
منذ حارس الحائط مايو
2021 حركة لها أذرع إقليمية لها
الحضور الإقليمي في لبنان وأماكن أخرى، وذلك
يعكس الإجراء المسمى نمو لحم الخنزير
والتي تحولت من حركة تأسست في قطاع غزة إلى موافق
في ترتيب
87 لحركة أكبر من أبعاد الشريط
صدى الحركة في لبنان هار روري يأتي من قرية مجاورة
الرملة أعتقد أنه ينبغي التركيز بشكل كبير جدًا
على اليوش بشكل رئيسي على لواء بنيامين والخوف
أكبرها هي خريطة شاف في أكتوبر في المستوطنة
في لواء بنيامين، أفترض تماما أن قوات الجيش
منذ فترة طويلة أعتقد أن الاحتياطيين هم ضيوف
وجبات الطعام لهذا هو ما يجب أن ينتبه إليه الرجل
ورئيس أركان الهجادة في حماس مسؤول أيضًا عن ذلك
عامين من هجمات حماس بهذا الرجل هو المسؤول
هذا الرجل مع الكثير من الدماء على يديه وصالح
هل من قضى عليه من قضى عليه نحن
بحاجة إلى الاهتمام نحن بحاجة إلى الاهتمام
أن تكون إيرانيًا جدًا جدًا أيضًا في الشمال وفي كل شيء
ما قلناه عن حزب الله صحيح، ولكن أيضاً عن توفير الأفراد لأنه
منذ أن كان رئيس الأركان كثيرًا جدًا
قد نكون كذلك
سيحاولون اختطافنا
من هناك